so one of the most eye-opening
experiences for me was the Arab Spring
right
the Arab Spring highlights to you that
one person changes changes to people
they change four people and then eight
million people show up in Tahrir Square
right and and that has been happening
over and over and over on the web right
it's just a matter of me changing three
things I swear
our humanity relies on three things one
is that you realize that you were born
happy it's your absolute birthright that
anyone who told you you don't deserve to
be happy
or that it that happiness is
unattainable was lying right two is that
you invest in it just like you go to the
gym to have a good body how many of us
spend an hour a day investing in our
happiness watching a video reading a
book
spending time with happy people
discussing the topic of happiness just
like we do with everything that we set
our minds to and then number three which
is the most critical part of humanity
today is can we have the compassion in
our heart now that we learned something
about happiness to make another happy
yes if you can make another happy and
make them promise to make another happy
we're gonna get to a billion in five
years it's as simple as that I always
say tell two people who will tell two
people who will tell two people and just
focus on yourself just keep going back
to you and saying okay I'm gonna just
repeat I'm going to now go back invest
another hour learn something new and
tell to people and tell them to tell to
people right that's it
it's a pretty simple action item it's a
very simple action item it would change
our world now the real question is this
how many of us have experimented with
the lie and noticed that it's not
working how many of us have earned the
hundred dollars they were expecting when
they graduated from school and then said
no no no I want a thousand and then when
they got the thousand they said I want
fifty and when they got fifty they said
I want a hundred thousand only when I
get 120 I'll be happy right and it never
really happens how many of us have
realized that we really inside because
every
I meet is a good person believe it or
not inside without our egos were all
good people right how many of us inside
are saying I just don't like the fact
that I'm so annoying right I don't like
the fact that I am so so pretending to
be what I'm not
I just want to undress just want to go
to work tomorrow and say look I'm
stressed you know can you go to your
manager and say hey by the way I just
don't like this job can we work together
for the next six months to find me
another job and find you a better person
right and what's the worst that can
happen he's gonna go crazy and fire you
if he's that crazy he doesn't deserve
your time anyway right and you're gonna
be fine you're not gonna starve to death
it is all of those things that we're so
blinded by and we're just moving through
life accepting the the false promise
when it's about time to change
I like the push for daily analysis of
happiness within oneself and then also
within the community yeah that that
that's great
Momo it's a very simple action item that
I think that we can all do are you guys
excited to do that yeah wake you up a
bit give it a little conversation
rolling all right all right